democratic debate where ten presidential
candidates showed a clear divide between
the party's political center and its
left wing it was the first time that all
the top Democrats in this race appeared
together they displayed sharp divisions
on a range of issues including health
care and in a first there were three
women to African Americans one Latino
and one Asian on the stage telling
voters why they should be the next
president
O'Keefe is in Houston where he covered
the debate last night at good morning
who set themselves apart and how they do
it
well good morning the differences were
somewhat apparent on several of the
issues last night over the course of
three hours perhaps the differences were
most stark right there at Center states
where the national frontrunner former
Vice President Joe Biden a moderate was
sandwiched between two liberals senators
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders
bienvenidos at the house houston we have
a problem a battle of the big ten
Democrats in Houston focused especially
on the top issue of concern health care
and how to pay for it costs are going to
go up for wealthier individuals and
costs are going to go up for giant
corporations former Vice President Joe
Biden and other moderates repeatedly
pressed senators Elizabeth Warren and
Bernie Sanders for how they would pay
for their Medicare for all plan my
friend Vermont thinks that the employer
is going to give you back if you
negotiate his union all these years got
a cut in wages because you got insurance
they're gonna give back that money to
the employee matter of fact they will
well let me tell you something for
socialists you gotta get first socialist
you got a lot more confidence in
corporate America than I do I trust you
to choose what makes the most sense for
you not my way or the highway
so I know a lot of doctors and they tell
me that they spend a lot of time on
paperwork avoiding being sued and
navigating the insurance bureaucracy the
most combative moment of the night when
former housing secretary who Leon Castro
accused Biden of flip-flopping on
whether people who can't afford health
care would be automatically enrolled in
Biden's health care plan do not have to
buy you do not have to buy just two
minutes ago I mean I can't believe that
you said two minutes ago that they had
to buy in and now you're saying they
don't have to buy you're forgetting that
the three hour debate at Texas Southern
University a historically black
University included calls for stricter
gun control in the wake of two recent
mass shootings in the state background
checks and gun licensing these are
agreed to by over whelming Lee the
majority from Americans it is
traumatizing our children El Paso and
they don't God love you for standing so
courageously in the midst of that
tragedy I met the mother of a 15 year
old girl who was shot by an ar-15 and
that mother watched her bleed to death
over the course of an hour because so
many other people were shot by that
ar-15 in Odessa in Midland there weren't
enough ambulances to get to them in time
hell yes we're gonna take your ar-15
your ak-47
so we caught up with who Leon Castro
after the debate to try to clarify with
him what exactly he was trying to do
there with the former vice president we
went over the transcript there live on
CBS n he insists that this was a
disagreement over healthcare policy but
others in the room said that it was a
low blow or perhaps a politically
suicidal move this much we know
lesser-known contenders who've gone
after the former vice president in
previous debates ended up losing their
support and are no longer in the race
alright big lesson there and thank you
very much